I'm thinking of taking Artemisidin for a metastatic bone cancer.
This is in the store, what would be your opinion of which one to use?
I would use the Artemisidin solo.
We used to use the Artemisidin.
We have several Artemisidins.
The Artemisidin solo by research nutritional.
It's a white bottle with a yellow label.
I think it's a really clean product.
It's called Artemisidin solo.
I know others who have had cancer and have killed it and just do not know how to supplement to use.
I would use that one.
Artemisidin is, I haven't talked about Artemisidin for a long time.
It's a great product for bacteria as well.
As a matter of fact, it is kind of a bush that grows in like a shrub.
And it is native to Africa in multiple different areas.
Artemisidin and anua, the name of the plant.
And it will kill all sorts of different diseases.
It is great for live disease as well.
It could be very helpful for cancer patients.